les Américains ont fait des
constatations
ils ont fait des interventions ils ont
abattu le fameux ballon qui était un
ballon chinois en saura avec l'analyse
il y avait des appareils qui étaient
destinés à espionner ou pas probablement
d'ailleurs c'est la loi dans ce dans
cette planète et puis il y a deux autres
ovnis qui ont été abattus qui sont
appelés par l'armée américaine des ovnis
et l'armée américaine n'exclut pas le
fait que ce soit des objets volants non
identifiés d'origine extraterrestre
alors ça
j'ai lu la note hein
on a l'impression d'en avoir tous les
jours qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors je ne suis pas l'ambassadeur ou le
porte-parole d'une éventuelle
civilisation extraterrestre je pense
d'ailleurs que évidemment nous ne sommes
pas seuls dans l'Univers évidemment nous
ne sommes pas seuls dans la galaxie
nous avons été visités nous sommes
visités en ce moment même par une ou
plusieurs civilisations extraterrestres
ça j'en ai la certitude absolue fait 50
ans que je travaille sur les dossiers
ils ne sont pas hostiles en ce sens que
nous nous attaque pas des choses
comment on sait pas d'où ils viennent
ils ont des ils ont des passeport
de visite mais je pense et ce sera
l'objet d'ailleurs d'une de mes
prochaines enquêtes avec le milieu
scientifique je pense qu'il voyage dans
le temps ce qui expliquerait beaucoup de
choses c'est à dire que nous on les voit
depuis des milliers d'années dans notre
temps à nous mais dans leur temps à eux
il s'est peut-être écoulé un ou deux
jours
parce que leur temps est beaucoup plus
long que le nôtre pas du tout si vous
avez la capacité de voyager dans le
temps mais on va prendre une image vous
êtes sur une planète d'extraterrestre et
vous avez
2000 ovnis numéro 1 numéro 2 jusqu'à
2000 avec 2000 pilotes
le chef d'État dit vous allez partir sur
la planète Terre toi pilote de l'ovni
numéro un tu vas aller en l'an et toi
pilote 2000 tu vas aller en l'an 2000 et
vous revenez dans 24 heures
nous on va aller voir pendant 2000 ans
et pourri ce serait écoulé 24 ans c'est
ça le voyage dans le temps
et est-ce que si c'était des
extraterrestres est-ce que on pourrait
les abattre aussi facilement
alors je ne sais pas quelle est leur
armement quels sont leurs capacités de
fuite ou d'interception de nos
éventuelles avions les plus
perfectionnés comme le Raptor qui est
supérieur au F-35
mais je pense que évidemment ils ont des
capacités technologiques bien
supérieures aux autres qui doivent
savoir instantanément ce que nous
pensons ce que nous avons l'intention de
faire donc imaginez qu'on va pouvoir les
descendre comme ça je pense que c'est un
peu naïf alors
aujourd'hui donc on a eu Gilles on a eu
quand même des faits incroyables oui et
ce qui est hallucinant il faut savoir
que les États-Unis ont une culture du
secret là dessus c'est à dire qu'ils ont
enterré des affaires ils ont tué ils ont
caché et d'ailleurs vous avez sorti des
dossiers des dossiers sortent mais là
pour que le général vende R qui a une
sommité du Pentagone disent c'est un
général qui dit vous en êtes je
n'exclure rien
c'est presque une reconnaissance d'un
mystère alors il y a eu les ballons
chinois mais il y a autre chose et moi
Jean-Claude je suis à vos côtés j'espère
ils vont arriver et comme vous je leur
ouvrirai mon coeur en leur disant venez
pour que nous puissions bénéficier de
leur technologie
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant il dit il dit le général
c'est au service c'est derrière nous
c'est au service de contresionnage Au
service secret de voir ce qu'il y a
c'est énorme pour que les États-Unis je
n'excuse rien en français ça veut dire
je n'ai aucune idée je sais pas non non
non
sinon tu aurais dit j'excuse la piste
extraterrestre maintenant à voir
Jean-Claude vous avez raison Cyril non
franchement
c'est c'est la logique même de celui qui
sait appréhender la langue française et
son site et son sens quand vous avez le
grand patron effectivement de l'armée ou
de l'armée de l'air qui dit je n'exclure
rien c'est exactement ce que vous venez
de dire c'est à dire
les extraterrestres c'est ce que vous
Jean-Claude qui avait travaillé depuis
des années là-dessus est-ce que vraiment
les extraterrestres est-ce que peut
est-ce qu'on peut avoir croisé des
extraterrestres voilà peut-être dans
notre vie et on le sait pas
bien sûr vous savez il y a une
déclaration qui m'a beaucoup frappé
c'est celle de ce qu'on appelle l'ovni
est un général de salle de l'armée
israélienne qui est professeur
d'université qui a eu trois fois les
plus hautes décorations israélienne
c'est lui qui a mis pendant 30 ans en
place le système de satellite
d'observation et de protection d'Israël
c'est pas n'importe qui il a toute sa
tête il a déclaré il y a 18 mois nous ne
sommes pas seuls évidemment dans
l'univers et il y a une race
extraterrestre qui nous visite
ça a été repris mais on était en pleine
covid donc on a parlé de ça un jour le
lendemain on a parlé de la covid etc qui
sont il faut reprendre ces déclarations
vous les trouvez sur le web ils viennent
sur terre comme ça ils repart alors moi
je n'exclut pas et j'ai des raisons de
dire cela je n'exclus pas qu'il y ait
des représentants ou des terriens qui
sont en contact avec une race
extraterrestre sur la planète
terreiens qui parleraient avec des
extraterrestres
aussi parmi nous dans ces messages avec
un petit point d'interrogation je
n'oublie pas de ce qu'a dit le président
de la Russie m'aide vedev qui a fait une
déclaration il savait pas qu'il était
filmé mais on retrouve ça aussi sur le
web lui il dit la première chose qu'on
m'a expliqué quand j'ai été lu président
de la Russie après le Poutine et avant
que Poutine ne revienne il a dit on m'a
donné la liste des extraterrestres dans
tous les gouvernements de la planète
Terre ce que dire Ahmed et en France ça
semble absolument invraisemblable mais
ce n'est pas un premier ministre des
extraterrestres en France est-ce qu'il
en existe une
oui certainement bien sûr il en existe
une
vous en connaissez vous
personnellement je connais des
extraterrestres
[Rires]
évidemment mais je crois que vous lis
l'histoire de la planète Terre vous
savez j'ai relu avant de venir ici Pline
l'Ancien bien sûr c'était le premier
siècle après Jésus-Christ ça c'était
premier siècle après Jésus-Christ il y a
2000 ans qu'est-ce qu'il dit il a fait
une sorte de liste de toutes les choses
extraordinaires qu'il a vu ou dont on
lui a rapporté l'existence il dit sur un
champ de bataille en plein jour il y a
des boucliers ardents qui sont arrivés
vous savez un bouclier c'est rond alors
ça veut dire qu'il brûle qui s'arrête et
ben en 2023 on est incapable de dire ce
que ça pouvait être il y a 2000 ans donc
évidemment qu'on voit des ovnis depuis
des milliers d'années bien sûr et et
vous Jean-Claude comment on peut
reconnaître un ovni il a croyait tout de
suite
vous savez c'est eux qui ont la maîtrise
dans l'intelligence donc s'ils veulent
se révéler à nous ils ont les capacités
de le faire nous on est les plus
intelligents de la planète Terre mais
enfin il y a pas de quoi
il y a pas de quoi rouler les mécaniques
quand même quand on voit on en est à
2023 où il y a des guerres partout la
famille etc mais
s'ils veulent entrer en contact avec
nous et se manifester ils ont la
capacité de le faire moi je pense que
c'est pas une question
est-ce que l'extraterrestre à la
capacité de prendre la forme humaine
c'est une très bonne question
je me demande si s'ils n'ont pas la
capacité de prendre la forme humaine
s'il ne nous ressemble pas c'est à dire
est-ce que la vie sur d'autres planètes
parce qu'elle est programmée dans chaque
atome qui ont été qui ont l'existence de
l'univers c'est à dire 14 milliards
d'années parce que lui par exemple
regardez lui 14 milliards d'années il
fait très jeune mais il a 14 milliards
d'années la plupart d'entre nous
il y a Daniel gars voilà là
c'est un peu le journal
un extraterrestre il peut arriver
je ne suis pas encore une fois
l'ambassadeur des extraterrestres mais
je m'intéresse à ça depuis 50 ans il y a
des choses qu'on peut dire publiquement
il y a des choses qu'on peut pas dire
donc je ne dirai pas sur quelque chose
qu'on peut pas dire ça veut dire que il
y a des choses bien sûr évidemment
pourquoi on peut pas les dire
publiquement parce que ça fait
parce que déjà le fait de parler
d'extraterrestre vous voyez bien la
réaction notre ami que j'aime beaucoup
parce qu'il fait des blagues superbes il
y a la plaque d'immatriculation tout le
monde se met des extra sérieusement
ils sont pas prêts est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu est-ce que vous avez déjà vu des
preuves réelles qui te qui vous font
croire aux extraterrestres parce que
nous on attend des petites crottes
[Musique]
des personnes censées qui disaient tous
se racontaient tous à la même chose
moi j'y crois fou moi je te dis Jean moi
j'y crois à fond et je pense que si
extraterrestres viennent je pense je
suis un des premiers qui vont venir voir
bien sûr je pense vraiment à mon poste
dans l'enquête que j'ai fait récemment
j'ai repris des dossiers de l'armée qui
sont incontestables dans la BD là bien
sûr justement alors là il y a des vrais
révélations là OVNI révélation d'un
secret alors je peux vous dire là il y a
des révélations incroyables alors sous
forme de Bénin que des cas parfaitement
référencés tout à fait extraordinaire et
c'est pas quelqu'un qui a mis une petite
boule dans le ciel ce sont des cadettes
atterrissage avec des observations
d'être humanoïs alors lui il avait une
petite boule dans des slips mais il a
quand même des questions non parce que
tout est là vous avez dit quelque chose
de très intelligent Cyril merci
tout le cas comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour les exterminer mais pourquoi les
exterminer pourquoi
et c'est bien non mais c'est vrai et
peut-être moi la vérité je vous dis la
vérité
moi peut-être que je vais être hyper
peut-être que je vais être hyper copain
avec des extraterrestres
et peut-être que tu en es un alors merci
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Claude je sais qu'il y a plein de
choses que tu peux pas dire j'aimerais
vraiment que tu nous dises deux trois
petites choses quand même dans un
instant parce que je vous dis
Jean-Claude il s'est les trucs c'est
incroyable cette histoire
d'extraterrestres je vous le dis moi j'y
crois à fond et il y a plein de choses
qui sont cachées mais c'est vrai mais
c'est trop facile
tout ce qu'on peut demander
le reste on le dit on va vous dire un
truc vous allez voir non mais sans
charrier voilà je sais que tu as des
trucs aussi un truc troublant et c'est
vrai que en vérité Jean-Claude il y a
plus aucun doute on n'est pas les seuls
dans les dans l'univers il faut arrêter
de rêver non mais c'est vrai il suffit
de regarder le cosmos et surtout il
suffit d'aller sur le web et taper web
le we2b qui est le fameux télescope qui
est à 1500000 km de la Terre qui est
très loin donc de l'atmosphère qui fait
des photos absolument hallucinantes et
on découvre pratiquement une six par
jour il faut savoir qu'une galaxie c'est
100 milliards à 1000 milliards d'étoiles
qui entraînent des dizaines ou des
centaines ou des milliers de milliards
de planètes alors évidemment quand on
est pas seul dans l'univers évidemment
que la vie foisonne d'abord le ballon
chinois ensuite le 10 février Washington
annonce avoir abattu un objet volant à
haute attitude au-dessus de l'Alaska et
clairement le GAN a aucune idée de ce
que c'est et il l'a dit le porte-parole
de la démangeaison blanche on sait pas
qui c'est on sait pas qui on est le
propriétaire en février le Premier
ministre canadien Justin annonce qu'un
objet non identifié sur volonté est
abattu le style Trudeau hein
un quatrième objet est abattu par un F16
au-dessus du lac Huron dans le nord des
États-Unis donc là de qui quelques jours
il y a énormément d'objets non
identifiés donc j'ai volant non
identifié OVNI bien entendu et c'est
vrai que ça fait énormément parler et la
Maison Blanche n'exclut pas voilà
des extraterrestres voilà une exclut
rien c'est ce qu'ils ont dit et j'ai
même pas envoyé un document un petit peu
un petit peu confidentiel ou vraiment
c'est très touchy et voilà je vous
disent voilà c'est des extraterrestres
mais c'est une affaire vraiment
classique vraiment secret défense c'est
ça Jean-Claude j'ai eu voilà on m'a
envoyé un c'est très étonnant que la
Maison Blanche et que les plus hautes
autorités américaines
laissent ouverte l'hypothèse d'une
visite extraterrestre à mon avis c'est
de la communication pour préparer
quelque chose ou pour cacher quelque
chose parce que je ne comprends pas
comment l'armée américaine qui sait très
bien que les extraterrestres existent
depuis très longtemps je publiais il y a
50 ans une note secrète ultra secrète
d'ailleurs qui avait été déclassifiés
qui datait de 1947 qui était envoyé par
le grand patron des services secrets de
l'armée américaine au chef d'état-major
de l'armée de l'air et qui disait les
ovnis les soucoupes volantes
sont réels ce n'est pas une arme secrète
dans quelconque pays de cette planète
1947 alors vous imaginez bien que 70 ans
plus tard ils savent ce que c'est bien
sûr alors
j'y crois totalement je crois pas que un
F16 des gommes un ovni je pense pas
parce que ce sont des engins qui sont
capables en deux secondes d'aller
peut-être 500 fois la vitesse de la
lumière de traverser des galaxies et
tout le bordel donc ça je crois pas à ça
que un F-16 des gommes un ovni non ils
sont beaucoup tu imagines le nombre
d'années de millénaires qu'ils ont
d'avance sur nous on a un spécialiste
ici je vous demande pas votre avis en
vrai voilà parce qu'on dépasse pas oui
ou non croyez-vous aux objets volants
d'identifier on s'interroge vraiment sur
cette affaire où il y a eu 4 vraiment
objet volant mon identifié ok en très
peu de temps c'est la première fois
qu'on entend autant de choses on est
aussi peu de temps ah oui c'est
impressionnant donc moi je suis ça
depuis 50 ans depuis
j'ai jamais entendu quatre absolument
donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer
Jean-Claude vous avez sur la couverture
de la BD la fête dessinée par Pelletier
vous avez cette affaire du porte-avion
nucléaire limite en 2004 ou le radar
détecte quelque chose de bizarre ils
envoient une patrouille de F18 qui
arrive sur place en plein jour et il
voit ce qu'ils appellent un espèce
d'énorme tic-tac vous savez les petites
alors bon on va
devoirs sur deux ou trois mètres qui n'a
pas d'hélice qui n'a pas de système de
propulsion et qui est à 10 ou 15 mètres
au-dessus de la mer qui bouillonne
dessus
et et c'est parti à une vitesse telle il
y a d'ailleurs des vidéos qui sont qui
ont été diffusées par l'armée de sa
sortie à une vitesse telle que ils ont
été laissés sur place et l'appareil a
fait 500 km en quelques secondes oui
alors admettons qu'il y a une race extra
terrestre pourquoi on nous le cacherait
c'est ça quoi en fait pourquoi d'abord
ça dépend peut-être pas de nous c'est à
dire que si nous avons à faire une
civilisation qui est nettement
supérieure et s'ils viennent nous voir
ils sont nettement supérieurs à nous et
je n'exclut pas qu'il y ait aussi une
base ou des bases sous la mer parce que
j'ai beaucoup de témoignages sous la mer
il faut pas oublier que la profondeur
moyenne des océans c'est 3 km 700 mais
il y a des fausses de 10 km donc et on
sait pas aller là-dessous alors
Jean-Claude pourquoi il y a autant et ça
c'est ça c'est une question qui se pose
énormément les téléspectateurs parce que
si vous nous rejoignez à 20h35 4 objets
volants non identifiés en quelques jours
c'est vraiment très très rare comme nous
l'a dit Jean-Claude c'est pratiquement
jamais arrivé il y a beaucoup de gens
qui se posent des questions pourquoi
il y a autant de secrets autour de ça et
on dit partout dans tous les pays il y a
une cellule vraiment extrêmement secrète
qui traite des extraterrestres est-ce
qu'il y en a dans tous les pays parce
que je sais que en France ils n'ont rien
à voir aussi en France il y a le GPS qui
est payé par
par le ministère je sais plus lequel je
crois des armées ou profiter ça et qui
s'occupe de ça qui s'occupe des objets
volants dans les galettes
c'est un extraterrestre j'ai été victime
d'un cambriolage de documents qui
étaient par extraordinaire mais qui
était quand même confidentiel on est
venu me cambrioler chez moi dans le 15e
en plein jour pendant une absence sans
effraction sans effraction on a juste
voler une photo qui était hyper
importante c'est tout ils ont rien volé
d'autres
une photo c'est tout et
j'ai été tellement stupéfait je suis
allé voir le directeur de la gendarmerie
de l'époque que je connaissais puisque
je travaille toujours pour la
gendarmerie
je lui ai dit écoutez voilà ce qui m'est
arrivé il m'a dit ça c'est un coup des
Russes je vais je vais vous faire
rencontrer des gens des services secrets
français donc j'ai rencontré des gens
des services secrets français au plus
haut niveau
et ils m'ont dit la même chose ils m'ont
dit ça c'est un peu des Russes mais j'ai
dit mais pourquoi ils ont pénétré chez
moi j'ai une porte blindée il faut quand
même savoir fracturer une serrure sans
faire fracturer alors qu'il suffisait
d'ouvrir la boîte aux lettres quand j'ai
reçu ce document venant des États-Unis
ils vont dire mais ça c'est un coup des
Russes quand même donc si vous voulez
c'était il y a au moins 40 ans j'ai
constaté que les services secrets au
plus haut niveau en France n'étaient pas
du tout étonné par les histoires de
soucoupe volante et que ça les faisait
Paris avec un double salto arrière et
donc je me suis dit ils savent des
choses que moi je ne sais pas alors
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on sait des
choses que l'on ne sait pas justement
parce que là c'est ce qui interroge nos
téléspectateurs ce soir surtout quand on
voit autant de faits comme ça quatre
objets volants non identifié ce qu'ils
auraient pu est-ce qu'ils auraient voulu
le cacher ça
face à l'opinion publique vous imaginez
bien qu'un gouvernement quel qu'il soit
là on n'est pas dans la droite et dans
la gauche là on est l'humanité face à
une autre humanité ou à une autre forme
d'intelligence ou à d'autres formes
[Rires]
aujourd'hui mais comme on a dit tout à
l'heure
qu'est-ce que ça changerait de dire
voilà nous ne sommes pas les seuls dans
l'Univers qu'est-ce que ça changerait
parce que comme vous l'avez dit est-ce
qu'ils veulent vraiment ils veulent
peut-être pas de mal les extraterrestres
peut-être que voilà c'est juste ils sont
d'une autre planète et eux ils visitent
aussi ce qui se passe
vous imaginez ce que ça impliquerait un
extraterrestre qui viendrait avec toute
sa connaissance qui aurait des milliers
des dizaines de milliers des centaines
de milliers d'avance il dirait vous êtes
en train de manifester contre la
retraite à 64 ans et ben voilà je vais
vous donner cette petite pilule vous
allez vivre 2000 ans non elle est où
cette pilule
c'est incroyable donc c'est des
différences d'intelligence et de culture
et d'appréhension du cosmos qui sont
absolument colossales donc on peut
imaginer qu'ils sont bienveillants quand
même ce que j'ai envie de dire que
l'armée américaine avait vu au-dessus de
fukusima par exemple tout d'un coup il y
a eu l'apparition de beaucoup de qui
venait jeter un coup d’œil moi je pense
que si Poutine voulait déclencher une
guerre nucléaire je pense qu'il serait
là pour le pour l'interdire je pense
qu'il n'aurait pas envie que la planète
se détruise moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont plutôt s'ils sont là ils sont
bienveillants alors il y a quelque chose
qui m'a frappé dans le dossier des ovnis
c'est qui surveille beaucoup l'énergie
nucléaire si par exemple en 2018 la
centrale de Fessenheim qui marchait
encore a été survolée pendant plus d'une
heure par plusieurs ovnis qui ont été
parfaitement décrits par les témoins des
ovnis qui étaient triangulaires qui
faisait au moins 20 mètres de diamètre
stationnaire 20 minutes on sait pas ce
que c'est pas des sandwich triangles
Cyril ça voudrait dire que possiblement
c'est pour ça que le secret notamment en
France a été gardé sous une charte de
plomb possiblement nous pourrions
devenir entre guillemets une colonie
d'une puissance extraterrestre donc
c'est insupportable pour l'être humain
moi j'ai un ami très proche je vais vous
raconter une anecdote un ami très
crédible très proche qui a fait une
rencontre dont la famille a fait une
rencontre qu'on appelle une rencontre du
troisième type d'accord ça c'est tout à
fait sérieux Jean-Claude c'est quand le
film voilà il y a type 1 on observe type
2 il y a des traces type 3 rencontre du
troisième type d'où le nom du film c'est
la rencontre direct avec des
extraterrestres sa famille dans l'Est de
la France que c'est surtout dans l'Est
en France a fait une rencontre directe
il a témoigné auprès des services c'est
impossible de rendre sa public ils ont
peur on les a dissuadés les témoignages
directs il reste seulement parce qu'on
n'a pas la rencontre puisqu'elle est ton
histoire et ce sont les ballons ils ont
fait une rencontre du 3e division
[Musique]
elle est nulle ton histoire moi aussi
demain je vais te dire j'ai vu un gars
si je te dis rien
avec les extra
cteurs ils ont descendu du vaisseau
[Rires]
bleu qui clignote
c'est des rencontres directes
ton histoire elle est nul mais non
excuse-moi je t'adore
c'est rien elles sont descendus mais ils
sont descendus je peux dire je suis
descendu
est-ce qu'ils sont verts je sais pas
s'ils sont là mais vous vous rendez
compte que c'est qu'ils ont Facebook
c'est classé secret défense et
Jean-Claude lecé c'est classé secret
défense parce que l'armée a tue toutes
ces rencontres directes avec les
extraterrestres franchement ton histoire
Jean-Claude juste qu'est-ce que ça peut
être donc c'est quatre objets dont
l'identifié qui ont été abattus ah alors
mon hypothèse personnelle mais je peux
me tromper comme tout être humain de
bonne volonté c'est que ce n'est
évidemment pas quelque chose
d'extraterrestre parce que je pense que
une civilisation extraterrestre
face à un raptor ça doit les faire
rigoler si tu es le sens de l'humour je
n'en sais rien je pense que c'est plutôt
peut-être des petits ballons qui sont
gonflés pourquoi j'aimais cette
hypothèse parce que les pilotes ont dit
il n'y avait pas de système de
propulsion apparent c'est pas des listes
pas de réacteurs etc donc il y a que
deux solutions ou c'est effectivement un
vaisseau extraterrestre qui utilisent
un moyen de propulsion du genre
qu'on connaît pas exactement ou alors
c'est un petit ballon qui est gonflé et
qui se balade il était pas gros
puisqu'ils
de temps c'est ou de l'espionnage ou
bien c'est quoi c'est peut-être les
Chinois qui ont lâché plusieurs ballons
je pense que c'est ça tu penses que
c'est ça
Jean-Claude juste pour parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a plein de choses tu dis je
peux pas dire plein de choses parce que
c'est compliqué de les dire à la
télévision quel genre de choses tu ne
peux pas dire
[Rires]
il y a des choses que tu n'as pas le
droit de dire est-ce que tu peux nous
dire quelles sont ces choses
une seule fois dans une interview je le
regrette pas parce que maintenant j'ai
81 ans donc qu'on se moque de moi j'ai
l'habitude c'est ok
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave j'ai dit
une seule fois écoutez bien ce que je
veux dire parce que je ne le répéterai
j'ai reçu sur TF dans un journal de 20
heures un monsieur
que je n'identifierai pas plus que cela
qui a pénétré dans mon cerveau c'est à
dire que j'ai senti comme une pieuvre
qui rentrait dans mon cerveau et j'ai
tout de suite compris que c'était
quelqu'un qui était un représentant
venant d'une autre planète alors quand
je dis ça on va dire je sais comment
réagit bourré alors ça y est il est
complètement allumé mais moi je sais ce
que j'ai vécu je sortais du maquillage
je pensais à tous aux fausses
extraterrestres j'étais concentré je
présentais le journal de 20h il a effacé
de ma mémoire ce qui s'est passé ensuite
on peut le retrouver il suffit que je
regrin que je regarde évidemment puisque
j'ai présenté le 20h de TF1 pendant 13
ans tous ceux que j'ai il y en a pas eu
beaucoup tous les hommes politiques
c'était pas un artiste c'était pas un
sportif pas mal c'était un politique
c'était peut-être un ambassadeur je sais
plus exactement mais ça a été effacé
j'ai senti je ressens encore j'en ai
même pas parlé à ma femme donc j'ai
ressenti comme une pieuvre qui rentrait
dans mon cerveau
j'étais très serein j'ai pas du tout eu
peur et je suis allé présenter le
journal et vous voyez j'en parle pour la
première fois j'en ai parlé une seule
fois parce que je refuse d'en parler
mais comme on est entre amis et puis que
j'ai participé à la naissance de cette
émission là ce sera la fin de cette
émission parce qu'ils vont nous
désintégrer
il faut cette histoire vraiment et
depuis il y a un truc qui a changé en
toi ou pas
changer psychologiquement évidemment
j'évolue comme tout être humain je j'ai
fait énormément de progrès je lis sans
fausse modestie dans la connaissance du
sens de la vie là je suis en train de
travailler sur les religions hindoues et
sur les vies Manas puisque on voit très
bien que les extraterrestres se sont
répandus partout sur la planète Terre
depuis des milliers d'années on le
trouve dans toutes les religions ce qui
veut dire que à partir de là on peut
peut-être unifier ces guerres de
religion qui n'ont aucun sens
Jean-Claude est-ce que tu en as déjà
rencontré d'autres ce sentiment de
quelqu'un qui rentrait dans ton cerveau
comme une pieuvre alors quand j'étais
quand j'étais petit à
Saint-Gervais-les-Bains effectivement
j'ai une rencontre rapprochée du
troisième type bon j'en parle maintenant
parce que je me fiche perdument de ce
qu'on peut dire sur moi mais oui à la
lisière de la forêt je me souviens très
bien il y avait deux boules et j'ai eu
une peur très bien absolument immense de
boules oui debout
c'est aussi pour ça ils ne prennent pas
contact avec nous parce que des vendus
ils sont tellement débiles c'est tout
c'est vrai ils se disent on est
tellement à la ramasse que ah oui non
non mais c'est debouts qui faisait à peu
près je sais pas deux trois mètres de
diamètre donc c'était pas une paire de
machin comme tu l'as eu
ou alors
[Rires]
je me souviens très bien de la peur que
je ressens encore qui n'était pas une
peur comme on peut avoir peur quand on
est dans un couloir la subir c'est un
copain qui sort qui fait ou non c'était
quelque chose qui émettait cette peur
oui pardon est-ce que vous avez déjà
senti vous quand je vous ai pénétrer à
l'antenne quand vous avez présenté aussi
une émission merci tu vois il a dit il
va il viendront jamais les
extraterrestres avec des gars drôles
Jean-Claude est-ce qu'il y a des raisons
de s'inquiéter ou pas
ça dépend ni de moi ni de mon analyse ça
dépend d'eux et s'ils viennent dans leur
temps à eux il s'est peut-être écoulé
deux ou trois jours dans leur temps
alors qu'on les voit depuis des milliers
d'années c'est ce qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre c'est la différence de temps
je le raconterai dans un prochain livre
des je suis en train de finir
Pascal Pelletier OVNI révélation d'un
secret alors là il n'y a que des cas
extraordinaires exactement
des cas d'atterrissage enquêté par
l'armée avec des traces qui sont
relevées etc et des petits bonhommes qui
descendent de ces ovnis
ils sont comment alors dans tes trucs là
ouvre la BD
alors en général il y en a qui nous
ressemblent il y a plusieurs races
d'accord d'après les témoins bien sûr il
y a plusieurs races qui nous visitent il
y en a qui qui sont tout à fait
semblables à nous il y en a d'autres qui
sont beaucoup plus filiformes et
d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus petit
avec une tête plus volumétrique que la
nôtre alors ça c'est l'affaire de
Monsieur il y a d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de films qui ont été fait
là-dessus parce que ça a été très bien
enquêté par la gendarmerie nationale le
SIRPA d'ailleurs a toujours parfaitement
renseigné les journalistes d'accord à ce
propos et
il y a des dessins qui reprennent les
rapports de gendarmerie là-dedans vous
verrez les dessins qui reprennent les
rapports de gendarmerie vous verrez la
tête des extra-tiens merci merci
Jean-Claude bourré merci d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui merci d'avoir un
bonheur est excellent